nous allons terminer ces rendez vous de
dimanche en compagnie de madame simone
de beauvoir qui a accepté de venir c'est
exceptionnel pour nous parler d'un film
simone de vous voir réalisé par josée
dayan qui est à ma gauche et mal car
ibos cac est à ma droite je voudrais
vous demander si cette chanson de vie on
vous a beaucoup touchés car je sais
qu'il ya des chansons que vous aimez
d'autres que vous aimez - mecelec fait
partie celle que vous aimez
oui j'aime beaucoup et puis ça nous rend
un peu les souvenirs ça me rappelle les
souvenirs et je la trouve toujours très
bien au présent je voudrais vous
remercier madame d'avoir accepté cette
invitation au nom de la chaîne que je
représente car vous êtes fait très très
rare dans votre vie sur les plateaux de
la télévision
mais ce film qui vous concerne et
quelque chose d'important pour vous
certainement
alors avant de donner la parole à celles
que réaliser ce film
je voudrais vous demander pourquoi vous
avez attendu si longtemps pour vous
raconter devant une caméra et pourquoi
vous avez choisi le cinéma plutôt que la
télévision est bien d'abord au modèle
jamais demandé de me raconter devant une
caméra
ensuite il ya eu une conjonction
heureuse j'ai rencontré malgré bouscat
et josée dayan à venise en bo de la
femme en plus elles m'ont proposé
différents films sur moi et comme
j'avais beaucoup de confiance en elle
qu'une réalisatrice puisque ce que la
femme rompue et beaucoup de sympathie
personnelle pour elle eh bien j'ai fait
ça avec beaucoup beaucoup de plaisir je
sais d'ailleurs vous avez enregistré
combien d'heures de conversation on a
enregistré douze heures de conversation
et je dois dire que ça a été ça la
difficulté parce que c'est très très
difficile de couper parce que les 12
heures de patience et des cruelles comme
parce que chaque fois été tentée de de
garder plutôt une chose qu'une autre
enfin il fallait néanmoins avoir un
squelette et il fallait pas dépasser 2
heures oui mais tout était complètement
passionnant et
on projette vraiment un jour de faire
encore un film avec les lycées 8 autre
heure vous avez vous tourné dans quel
lieu à paris on a tourné chez simone de
beauvoir on attendait c'est jean paul
sartre c'est à peu près tout j'ai déjà
gardé olga bost oui c'est ça et c'est
tout ce qu'on entend beaucoup de choses
se sont faites chez vous le tout les
tous les entretiens pratiquement se sont
faits à paris et puis on a fait
certaines évocation des lieux vont qui
était important pour nous dans le film à
marseille à rouen à rome et à venise où
simone bauer avait enseigné
alors au début de ce film à la une
question de claude lanzmann timone de
pouvoir vous dites que on pourrait dire
que j'ai accepté de faire ce film par
vanité parce que j'ai envie que les gens
me connaissent et vous ajoutez également
et même d'être reconnus et également de
dissiper peut-être un malentendu oui car
vous considérez compte que les
journalistes qu'une certaine presse n'a
pas toujours écrit des choses conforme à
ce que vous souhaitiez oui certainement
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ne m'ont pas
lui et qui me connaissent uniquement à
travers des rapports de journalistes qui
ne m'ont pas lui non plus par conséquent
cela donne de moi très souvent à l'image
tout à fait fausses et alors je pensais
que ce film m'aiderait rectifier son
image faussée de deux mois l'image sans
doute plus vivante et plus vrai qu est
ce qu est ce qui était écrit vous
concernant qui vous a le plus déplu
c'est j'ose dire qu'ils étaient le qui
était complètement faux od quand ils
chose je veux pas revenir sur les
détails mais par exemple l'accueil qui a
été fait au deuxième sexe convergence
que c'était vraiment un livre il faut
dire que il ya 30 ans et l'époque ce
n'était pas la même qu'aujourd'hui on a
trouvé que je tourner en dérision le mal
français par exemple m'a dit camus pour
qui j'ai beaucoup d'amis qui est non
seulement pour toucher et enfin beaucoup
d'autres comme mauriac enfin beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres ont pensé que c'était
un livre scandaleux faut sans intérêt
etc
on va y revenir tout allait alors dans
ce film vous vous racontez vous parlez
de votre enfance de votre rencontre avec
jean-paul sa police voix et puis de
votre et de vos engagements
ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé dans le début
de ce film c'est que vous dites que dès
l'âge de
8 9 10 ans vous aviez déjà envie d'être
écrivain de devenir écrit oui et je
crois que cette vocation ne déplaisait
pas votre père loin de là on dit que
votre père considérait que d'être
écrivain c'était socialement très bien
oui ses désirs qu'il avait beaucoup
d'intérêt pour les et raturer pour les
intimes
mais ceci dit alors les premières choses
que j'ai écrite c'est vraiment des
avantages sur copier des choses que
j'avais lu d'ailleurs je crois que
beaucoup d'enfants sur la même chose
sans qu'il devienne plusieurs écrivains
je crois que la vocation s'est affirmée
à peu près comme j'ai eu 15 ans et là
alors vraiment je mets beaucoup beaucoup
lire
j'avais beaucoup certains livres et je
souhaitais écrire des livres qu'ils
fassent les mêmes pressions sur des
jeunes et sur des femmes surtout que le
moule up sur la flotte par exemple avait
fait sur moi et a vraiment j'avais envie
d'être écrivain voulait faire rêver je
voulais communiquer si ça vous parler
assez peu dans ce film de guerre rapport
vous avez avec votre famille avec vos
parents c'était de bons rapports
ils ont été absolument excellent jusqu'à
l'âge de 10 ans 11 12 ans et c'est à
quoi je dois je pense une certaine
solidité et ils sont devenus beaucoup
moins bon après parce que c'était un cas
tout à fait général des conduits à un
adolescent entre des licences leben plus
ou moins de sa famille et la famille est
fâché qu'on s'en éloigne
ils sont restés toujours avec moi très
amicaux très correcte et c'est enfin je
sentais très bien que mon père m'en
voulais de beaucoup de choses hein
particuliers de devenir un intellectuel
alors qu'en même temps
d'une certaine manière ça l'arrangé pas
ce que j'avais envie que je passe des
examens que je réussisse que j'ai
diplômés que des fonctionnaires enfin
n'y avait plus entre lui et moi c'est
l'espèce d'amour très profond qui avait
eu jusqu'à l'âge de métro 12 13 ans à
vous parler
de l'enseignement oui vous avez enseigné
d'ailleurs on le voit dans le film de
josée des flashs roinson marseille et
puis à paris et vous dit une chose qui
m'a beaucoup surprise quand j'étais
professeur je m'intéressais surtout à
ceux qui étaient en tête de ma classe
oui les élèves brillants les autres je
m'en occupe pas beaucoup oui y'a
peut-être c'est plus surprenant
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs parce que je
crois que maintenant il ya un rapport
plus vivant plus directe du professeur
avec sa classe donc il peut s'intéresser
aussi à des élèves qui sont nuls parce
qu'il sent quand même que ils ont
quelque chose en eux mais de mon temps
comme le cours était quand même plus ou
moins magistral
on s'intéresse aux élèves qui répondait
qu'il faisait d'exposer qui faisait une
bonne dissertation et celles qui se
taisaient et bien on ne peut pas taire
je me critique m'a même un peu dans le
film je dirais t il hittistes est
certainement mais je ne suis pas sûr que
ce ne serait pas encore aujourd'hui dans
les second sa synagogue c'est à dire que
forcément sur les élèves qui parle qui
répondent qu'ils ont l'air intelligent
très les intéressés qui intéresse plus
aussi le professeur mais vous considérez
que vous étiez fait pour l'enseignement
ah oui ça j'avais toujours désir
enseigner j'ai enseigné dès l'âge de 5
ans puisque j'ai appris à lire à écrire
à bâtisseurs et je l'appelle lambert
jamais enseigné alors dans le dans le
film vous parler bien sûr de saint
germain des prés et surtout jean paul
sartre qui raconte qu'à votre retour
d'un voyage très enrichissant états unis
vous découvrez la mode d'existence et
dont on sait pas trop ce que voulait
dire à l'époque et jean paul sartre
évoque les souvenirs du fleur tout ce
qui se passait entre saint germès et
saint michel
oui je suppose que ça ça vous laisse
bien entendu un très très grand souvenir
c'est le souvenir d'amis d'amis que non
les amis que j'ai eus était fait en
dehors de ce mouvement dit socialiste a
par boris vian qui était vraiment dans
le
vivement qu'on disait existentialiste
qui n'avaient rien à voir venir avec la
philosophie existentialiste
mais leur boris vian oui c'était
vraiment un ami on va me trouver parce
qu'il ya un extrait d'ailleurs
[Musique]
il a reconnu là beaucoup de visages
connus invs a dit via gréco jean cocteau
claude lutter jean-paul ça bien sûr jean
genet yamaha cazalis et juliette gréco
simone novembre début de cette émission
il disait que pour elle cette époque
c'était une époque où on communiquait
beaucoup plus facilement
elle assistait justement sur les
rapports entre les gens qui fréquentent
et saint germain des prés et que ces
rapports n'ont plus cours maintenant que
les rapports au change et c'est votre
avis moi je ne ferais quand il passe à
jamal est prêt tu sors pas le savent pas
non
il venait de temps en temps à autre vous
étés au tabou deux fois dans ma vie mais
il avait alors fait fleurs et aux deux
magots mais nous y avions déjà pendant
la guerre avant qu'ils existentialisme
et puis nous avons d'ailleurs au
contraire cessé d'y aller leur dire de
ce moment où ça a été envahie par ce qui
se disait l'existentialiste c'est l'état
qui nous les amenons pas de trouver un
très gentil de ces légendes n'avions pas
du tout rapport avec 2
il y avait une grande différence des
générations puisque simple
existentialisme n'avait rien à voir avec
l'existentialisme philosophiques telle
que nous pensions s'apprendre certaines
drogues période d'amitié mais d'habitude
tout à fait d'autres gens déjà beaucoup
plus âgée des gens comme je sais pas que
nos les risques giacometti qu'il avait
rien à voir avec ça j'ai parlé par jean
paul sartre ajoute que cette époque là
vous avez quitté un peu saint germain
pour montparnasse et change un petit peu
de quartier c'est pas très juste sais
pas s'il l'a dit c'est exactement ça
m'étonne de ce qu'au contraire
montparnasse est elle si nous avions été
d'abord toute ma jeunesse moi j'ai passé
plus ou moins montparnasse toute la
guerre j'ai passé plus ou moins dom et
nous avons été plus tard sa femme à
l'épreuve mais nous n'avons pas beaucoup
fréquenté savoir les prêts en tant que
tel à la mesure où les boîtes tout ça
alors dans ce film josé et vaccari bosca
on voit bien entendu jean paul ça que
vous avez
rencontrez vous avez mis face à face
fois que vous connaissez très bien est
ce que ce n'était pas dangereux en tout
cas à risque et de mettre face à face
deux personnes qui se connaissent si
bien
ben je vois c'était la meilleure façon
de parler de de l'eau une trop grande
complicité environs de voir gens comme
ça pour pour maître jean-paul sartre
face à simone de beauvoir elle
interrogée moi je pense que qu'il était
pas envisageable de faire un film sur
simone de beauvoir sans la trouver face
à face avec jean paul sartre vous êtes
interview dans le film par jean-paul sa
douce est belle mais c'est ça vous fait
parler de la littérature
alors votre rencontre avec jean-paul ça
il ya beaucoup de spectateurs de
téléspectateurs qui ne savent pas
comment vous vous êtes rencontrés on
peut peut-être revenir sur cette époque
il était vous étiez sorbonnards comme
vous le dites oui c'est ça il était
normalien et et normalien ce qu'il
devienne un certain prestige et vous
dites que les premiers temps vous étiez
beaucoup plus attiré par un de ses amis
malgré ses pages étaient à tirer c'est
que mahut qui travaillaient avec moi le
national avait pris de l'amitié pour moi
et puis il nous voyons le début ensemble
elles mêmes conditions et gère déjà
beaucoup de se bâtir maheux et c'est un
peu plus tard qu'il m'a dit m'a mon
camarade siv aimerait bien faire votre
connaissance et prit alors au début
c'était comme ça un petit peu un jeu je
n'ai pas tout de suite rencontré j'ai
envoyé ma soeur faire comme il dit dans
le film d'ailleurs place et le samedi
pour ennemi les femmes vexé que c'est
souvent moi tu venu le plus petit à
petit il ya trouvé que pour préparer
l'oral dans l'agrégation parce que
j'avais un terreau su je pense à vous
inviter à venir
maheux
dix ans
et moi travailler avec lui ça s'appelait
pas le tournoi là c'était universitaire
avant dans sa chambre de ces universités
et là nous avons commencé à travailler à
discuter été rappelés à leurs devoirs et
puis sympathisent et là tout de suite
vous dites que vous avez remarqué
combien combien ce jeune homme ce jeune
étudiant était brillant intelligent et
il m'était supérieur dites vous dans le
film oui d'accord parce qu'elle était en
avance peut-être sur vous son plan de
ses études d'abord il avait troisième
plus ce qui quand on a 20 ans compte
beaucoup fait continuellement plus comme
il ya 50 mais personne à 20 ans ça fait
une différence
et puis l'été normaliens c'est à dire
qu'il est fait des élites beaucoup plus
solides comme moi qui avaient fait le
court désirons site est complètement nul
et puis qui mettait ensuite débrouiller
comme je pouvais être même me voir
arriver à passer la collation à la
sorbonne mais sans de loi être aussi
cultiver de lui alors en effet ça ça m'a
mise en vigueur et emma eux-mêmes
étaient sur ce plan là certainement
beaucoup plus cultivé vous annoncer que
moi alors ils étaient reçus premiers et
seconds bon il ya une grande ligue dans
le film grandes constantes dans votre
film il ya l'habitat le quartier il ya
l'oeuvre et pia jean paul sartre
oui vous connaissez jean paul sartre
depuis 50 à 7 50 ans est-ce que vous
avez été toujours d'accord sur tout en
tout cas sur l'essentiel sur l'essentiel
toujours certainement à 100 tout bien
entendu nous avons disputées nous ça va
discuter énormément sur des tas poids et
quelquefois d'une manière presque même
violente mais afin toujours en amitié
parce qu'après tout la discussion s'est
départi des rapports d'amitié et zaoui
discussion très très forte sur des tas
point les afriques ou autres enfin ça a
bien sûr il dit dans ce film que vos
premièrement il est trouvé qu'elle
compte parce que vos personnages ne
dialogue et pas assez et pas seulement
celles qui avaient des mal et puis
disait quelconque parce que ne m'étais
pas encore trouvé du tout ces mêmes il
est très gentil dit que c'était
quelqu'un c'est même très très mauvais
on poids que je n'ai même pas pensé les
proposé à l'éditeur le premier j'ai
proposé à l'éditeur
ça c'était déjà un peu plus valable
d'ailleurs pour les gens qui
s'intéressent je le fais à paraître
l'année prochaine parce que ça peut
amuser les gens qui m'aiment bien afin
de voir quels étaient les racines
l'origine de mes écrits mais c'était
c'était mauvais quoi est ce que vous
avez toujours bien accueilli la critique
de votre carrière jean paul sardi dans
le film la critique ça ne compte pas ça
n'a pas d'importance je les fasse il est
sincère en tout cas il semblerait que
j'ai dit tout à fait qu'il a dominé le
problème mais ce que vous vous êtes
senti de la critique
quelquefois dire que quand elle est trop
grossières prix tente en effet sa mère
ça me gêne mais dans l'ensemble ça ne me
gêne pas profondément parce que si en
effet un manuscrit je propose un
militaire a été bien reçue à la fois par
l'éditeur et par mes amis et par sartre
en particulier après ça ce que disent
les gens je pense que c'est plutôt eux
qui se trompent le contraire tout de
même quelques fois quand c'est vraiment
très bas très grossier comme ça arrive
pour une femme tout court puisque pour
un homme quand vous attaque sont déjà ne
disait pas ça me blesse c'est quelque
chose
nous disons sa visite alors dans votre
vie vous avez beaucoup voyagé
on m'avait dit avant cette émission j'ai
pas fais beaucoup de sport mais je fais
beaucoup de marche à pied
et oui bon marché oui
vous êtes allés aux quatre coins du
monde avec jean paul sartre quel est le
premier de ces voyages qui vous a le
plus marqué les voies de la première
fois que des halles aux états unis ah
oui ça m'a beaucoup marqué surtout que
l'on sortait d'une france exemple très
pauvre très que la retrouver l'abondance
lui seyait d'ailleurs d'étape côte est
des états unis
quand je n'aime pas du tout la politique
des états unis que ce soit contre leurs
amis en ligne via les codes et à deux
côtés de la vie aux états unis qui sont
tout à fait fascinant et qui pour moi
ont c'était fascinant constitue pour la
première fois des 1 147 ça c'était pour
moi une très très grande expérience il
ya un autre pays qui a beaucoup compté
dans votre vie c'est l'italie ah oui
c'est comme toujours face à l'italie
mais c'est passé comme la france pour
moi une france plus plus aimable par
rapport au climat aux gens à la beauté
la beauté de rome nous allons presque
toutes les heures avec sartre et venise
aussi nous sommes justement rencontré
avec les ai mal car nous avons beaucoup
sacre comme moi nous avons beaucoup
beaucoup l'italie est ce que vous aimez
cinéma italien beaucoup et le cinéma
américain
vous considérez vous savez que dans
cette émission de parlons beaucoup de
cinéma vous considérez que les deux
cinémas fort de notre temps système
américain c'est des méthodes
certainement en particulier chez les
mains italiennes
parce que il faut du cinéma politique
ils font du cinéma très vivant il faut
je n'aime pas tout bien sûr un film
italien ils ont des navets comme tout le
monde mais il ya un certain genre de
j'ai pas d'humour de distance en même
temps que deux sens du drame et de la
tragédie qui me touche beaucoup danser
les maîtres et j'aime beaucoup beaucoup
d'acteurs italien le cinéma américain le
nouveau cinéma américain pendant un
exemple est ce que le cinéma de woody
allen nous intéresse beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup will i am
personnellement j'ai pas vu son dernier
film intérieure mais j'aime beaucoup
tout ce qui fait ça beaucoup beaucoup
quand vous étiez étudiant vous alliez
souvent cinéma oui mais je voyais
surtout du cinéma d'avant-garde quand
j'étais étudiante et c'est ça qui m'a
initié au western et s'il était au
contraire on s'amuse on va surtout voir
les cinémas
tu as eue avec chose instant là ma faim
les cinémas difficile
puis petit à petit puis finalement j'ai
aimé enfin au cinéma presque tous ce
qu'est la bleue alors le cinéma nous
amène à la télévision je vais revenir
avec la vodka josée dayan pour la femme
rompue et eve étaient emportées à
l'écran il passe à la télévision
comment avez vous trouvé cette
adaptation et je veux savoir quelle
qu'est ce que ça a posé comme problème à
ma taille basse cac est un rôle à temps
rôle difficile c'est elle qu'il faut
parce que moi j'ai été enchanté de ce
qu'elles ont réalisé l comme actrice et
jeudi n'ayant réalisé
j'étais absolument enchanté été récitées
c'était complètement difficile à faire
moi j'avais lu le livre j'avais très
envie de le jouer comme personnage mais
c'était en effet un personnage qui va
tellement au fond d'une souffrance qui
descend tellement fond d'elle-même que
c'était un immense à l'immense travail à
faire et josé d'ailleurs m'a beaucoup
aidé à le faire voilà nous allons
revenir à votre film
le mouvement féministe ça c'est une
chose qui compte beaucoup pour vous et
vous parlais justement de des remous
qu'a provoqué la sortie de votre livre
deuxième 549 et là je vous avais donné
la parole à une femme qui compte
beaucoup il s'appelle richard zaoui qui
est une membre éminente des mouvements
féministes et c'est elle qui vous
interroge sur ce sujet on va peut-être
la retrouver maintenant sûrs nous
ramener à ce film qui est sorti je le
rappelle depuis déjà trois quatre jours
à paris un extrait du film simone de
beauvoir vous parlais justement quand
vous avez sorti le 2 ème siècle encore y
avait pas de mouvements de femmes il
avait parlé plus de féminisme et avait
rien vous et relativement seuls
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à l'époque où
il s'est passé une grande levée de
boucliers contre moi d'abord bien sûr il
ya eu quelques hommes qui m'ont soutenue
dont j'étais sur des airs de soutien
c'est à dire sartre malraux conti
francis jeanson quelques autres amis qui
étaient tout à fait tout à fait d'accord
avec le livre mais j'ai eu quand même de
grosses surprises parce que quelqu'un
comme camus par exemple que je ne
pensais pas du tout ma schiste en fait
peut-être du fait qu'il est
méditerranéen
je ne sais quoi a été furieux et a dit
que j'avais ridiculiser le mal français
et puis il ya un professeur que je
connaissais professeur de sorbonne qui
était un beau frère de merleau ponty et
qui a pris le livret qui nous vous les
lectures assez brève la jetée d'un bout
à l'autre de la salle dans la fureur et
il ya eu des articles extrêmement
désagréable à des hommes j'étais
humiliée d'être une femme etc alors je
voulais réponse de sa réutiliser les
hommes et les gens me regardaient
souvent dans les restaurants parce que
le livre avait quand même eu un certain
succès on ne met pas à vis de moi en
ricanant et on suppose un plus ou moins
du coude
il faut dire que c'était en 49
effectivement oui c'est ça d'ailleurs je
me souviens d'ailleurs j'ai relu des des
tas de choses là dessus vous parliez
d'ailleurs dedans
à cette époque-là de pour la première
fois on en parlait avec beaucoup de
discrétion d'ailleurs de la vie sexuelle
des femmes
oui c'est ça c'est ce qui a fait bondir
mondialisée on avait publié sa dans les
temps modernes et mon dieu à côté de
tout ce qu'on écrit aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas tellement hardiment fin josé en
parler et alors ça ça ça a révulsé
beaucoup d'un camion en particulier et
camus un particulier bon comment voyez
vous l'évolution des mouvements
féministes et comment voyez-vous
l'avenir des femmes de notre époque
je ne vois jamais l'avenir j'espère déjà
pas le marc de café j'ai pas de boulot
tout cas ce qui s'est passé pour elle
depuis la parution du deuxième sexe a
beaucoup évolué tout de même oui
beaucoup
il ya des progrès positifs oui
certainement je crois que depuis sept ou
huit ans les femmes ont pris un peu
leurs destins en main enfin certain
nombre des femmes elles sont obtenues
quand même certaines choses comme la
contraception comme l'avortement c'est
très très important
avant même de pouvoir être un peu un peu
je dis pas ce que c'est les lois sont un
peu tourné et salé ma faim et puis y'a
pas l'enseignement qu'il faudrait mafate
soit un peu plus libres de leurs corps
qu'elle ne l'était auparavant
et puis on est un peu pris conscience
quand même de ce que c'était que leurs
conditions et elles réclament davantage
l'égalité des salaires par exemple qui
est très très important parce que y'a
toujours un salaire beaucoup plus faible
pour les femmes pour des postes
identiques
en principe non la loi le refuse mais on
sari volontairement pour tricher pour
les vêtements
alors tout ça quand même il ya une
conscience des femmes et même d'un
mouvement qui sont très très mal machine
virage où m comme le parti communiste
tout de même les femmes commencent à
faire entendre leur foi et ça c'est très
important
donc je pense que rei évolution qui sera
kid paddle ne pas être favorable aux
femmes parce que c'est le mans
monstrueux l'annoncé viii lise et qu'ils
aient dit démocratique
c'est une telle différence entre les
hommes et les femmes salois petit à
petit ça j'en suis convaincu sa dépose
lesquelles je suis optimiste je pense
que je dois petit à petit sa tenue est
quand même dans un autre domaine quel
regard jetez-vous sur la jeunesse
actuelle
est-ce que vous avez le cadre de
rencontrer des jeunes se sentent non je
la connais peu et je pense qu'elle est
assez afin dans la mesure où de la
connaît à travers des gens qui la
connaissent je pense qu'elle était assez
désespérée et je ne m'en neten pas parce
que je trouve que le monde tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui
en tout cas en france aujourd'hui est
assez désespérant comment avez vous vécu
les événements 68 au avec une totale
sympathie mais sans y être vraiment très
engagée puisque je m'étais ni étude du
professeur
alors je me borner à assister à quelques
manifestations allaient la sorbonne à
écouter les jeunes qui parlait et une
trentaine sympathie à eux deux mais ce
n'était pas très militant ni très
efficace avant avec ça que nous avons
signé des nous avons fait jouer
cette proclamation était bourdy un autre
habitué aux étudiants enfin je n'étais
pas très très très engagé là dedans dit
les parents situation nous allons
revenir au film et l'a donné la parole à
jean paul sartre qui vous interroge qui
fait un petit peu le bilan de votre
c'est vers la fin du film
oui oui vous dis d'ailleurs on va
l'entendre que qui considère que votre
oeuvre comme la sienne elle est derrière
vous oui mais de ses passages du rugby
siens on va écouter votre réponse l'art
quand il va le faire aujourd'hui parce
que vous êtes comme moi vous l'avez à
fait prêt fermin et vous pourrez écrire
encore mais en gros
notre vrai diable je suis bien d'accord
alors donc on peut penser quelque chose
dessus on n'est pas en train de la faire
dedans on est d'or est finie alors
qu'est ce que enfin si je pense que j'ai
réussi à peu près ce que je voulais je
ne veux pas dire que c'est ce que tout
écrivain veut et vous avez vous lu
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'autres choses et
d'autres écrivains autre chose mais moi
ce que je voulais essentiellement
c'était donc parler je me rappelle que
je disais salariaux les différents j'ai
parlé aux gens précisé de bouche à
oreille parler de manière que les gens
s'identifient avec mais romero in ou
tirent profit de ce que je leur disais
et là je pense que je réussis parce que
le deuxième sexe un autre m'a fallu
énormément de lettres de femmes qui s'y
référer qu'il avait aidé j'ai même vu
des psychiatres qui m'ont dit s'en
servir pour faire prendre conscience à
certains de leurs malades certaines
surtout parce que ça a été surtout le
quai aux femmes bon donc là je pense
qu'il ya quelque chose qui a été assez
réussi et dans les autres romans et dans
ma biographie aussi est certainement
beaucoup de femmes qui sont plus ou
moins identifiés à moi ou pour chercher
en tout cas à penser une certaine ligne
de vie à partir de celle qui avait été
la mienne
donc sur ce plan là je pense que j'ai
fait ce que je voulais je n'ai pas
cherché des dé réussite extraordinaire
du côté de quoi que vous disiez très
gentiment que vous trouvez j'ai un
certain style j'espère dans certains
passages en effet on avait rugi pas du
tout écrit n'importe comment comme des
gens prétendent toujours beaucoup
travaillé ce que j'écrivais mais j'ai
quand même pas essayé d'être une
virtuose de l'écriture béton comme une
vie rien route c'est pas ça qui m'a
tellement intéressé et je n'ai pas
naturellement non plus cherché à rendre
compte d'une manière alors très réaliste
et mais qui peut-être et riche du monde
tel qu'il est à la façon c'est pas vrai
d'un balzac ou zola qui cherchait
vraiment à faire sortir le plus possible
de ma propre expérience dans l'exprimer
enfin tout ce que j'en étais tout ce qu
on était à mes yeux exprimable pour que
ça puisse servir d'une certaine manière
à autrui alors est-ce que vous est ce
que ça veut dire que vous
vous n'avez plus l'intention de nous
attaquer à des ouvrages très important
est ce que vous avez toujours
l'intention d'écrire et qu'elle dans
quelle direction je ne sais pas en effet
je pense que mon oeuvre est un peu
maintenant derrière moi que je n'ai plus
tellement de temps devant moi et je
n'imagine pas de m'attaquer à des
ouvrages de très longue haleine qui me
demanderait sa concision de travail
surtout que je ne pense pas que ça
ajouterait beaucoup à ce que j'ai dit je
pense que j'ai dis vraiment l'essentiel
tout ce que j'avais à dire maintenant et
la fin dit s'il venait l'espèce de
sollicitations d'inspiration ces listes
sont dehors inspiration du dedans et que
j'ai envie de dire quelque chose qui me
tiennent vraiment à coeur j'écrirai mais
je ne veux pas écrire pour écrire et je
n'ai jamais de dire écrit pour écrire si
j'ai rien à dire amiens je n'écrirai pas
y avoir quelque chose à dire ça signifie
beaucoup pour moi ça veut dire pas
simplement justement des bleus est tous
comme ça mais quelque chose qui me gêne
profondément
pour l'instant il n'y a rien voilà nous
avons essayé de parler de ce film sans
déflorer ce film d'une heure 50
il faut rappeler que ce film est sorti
on peut même parler des salles où il est
sorti dans trois salles il est sorti aux
racines au 14 juillet parnasse au 14
juillet bastille et il va sortir en
france dans le courant du mois de
janvier
et on peut penser que ce film passera un
jour sur tf1 pour cause à passer sur tf1
parce que justement jean louis guillot à
lui très grande bonté de nous l'acheter
avant même qu'on compte de tourner
oui voilà donc il va passer sur tf1
après sa nuit cinématographique à bien
et là bas ce sont plusieurs millions de
téléspectateurs qui pourront le voir
qu'ils pourront voir c'est une interview
d'une heure cinq ans je vous remercie
infiniment d'avoir accepté cette
invitation j'espère que youtube en
verront de temps en temps je crois que
c'est exceptionnel de voir sur un
plateau de télévision je voudrais vous
demander tout de même ce sera le mot de
la fin qu'est ce que vous pensez de cet
instrument magique qu'est la télévision
je pense pas sinon est dangereux pour
cambrai en faire un usage merveilleux
mais ce n'est pas tout vouloir garder
les buts en général je regrette surtout
les filles mes vieux films parce que
pour le reste le cas je vous ai vu la
dernière fois j'avais dit je suis pas
sûr pour les enfants c'est une bonne
chose
je ne sais pas très bien je pense que ça
peut leur apporter des choses mais c'est
également ça les pousse à la passivité
lire et quand même quelque chose d'un
peu plus difficile
les enfants de mon époque lise et
maintenant ils disent évidemment
beaucoup moins
c'est grâce à ces révisions ça encourage
à venir m passivité mais ça peut aussi
apporter des richesses salade
[Musique]